what do you think about
censorship in this space
in this
difficult space
where so much is controlled by
not controlled but influenced by
advertisements from big pharma
and science can even be influenced by
big pharma
where do you lean on this
should we
allow
lean towards freedom and just allow
all the
voices even those that go against the
scientific consensus
is that one way to fight
the
the science that is funded by big pharma
or is that do more harm than good
having too many voices that are
contending here should the ultimate
battle be fought in the space of uh
scientific publications
and particularly in the uh era of covid
where there are large public health
ramifications to the this public
discourse
the ante is way up
so
i don't have a simple answer to that
uh i think
everyone's allowed their own opinion
i don't think everyone's allowed their
own scientific facts
and how
we develop a mechanism
that's other than an open internet where
whoever is shouting the loudest
gets the most clicks and
the
rage creates value on the internet
i think that's not a good mechanism for
working this out
and i don't think we have one i don't
have a solution to this i mean ideally
if we had a philosopher king
we could have
a panel of people who were not
conflicted by rigid opinions
decide on
what the boundaries of public discourse
might be
i don't think it should be fully open i
don't think people who are making
who are committed to an anti-vaccine
position and will tailor their
interpretation of complex scientific
data to support their opinion
i think that can be harmful constraining
their speech can be harmful as well so i
don't have an answer here but
yeah i tend to believe that
it's more dangerous to censor anti-vaxx
messages
the way to defeat anti-vaxx messages
is by being great communicators
being great scientific communicators so
it's not that we need to censor
the things we don't like
we need to be better communicating
the things we do like or the things that
we do believe represent the
a deep scientific truth
because
i think
if you censor you get worse at doing
science
and you give the wrong people power
so
i i tend to believe that you should give
power to the individual scientists
and also give them the responsibility of
being better educators communicators
expressers of scientific ideas
put pressure on them to release data to
release that data in a way that's
easily consumable not just like very
difficult to understand but in a way
that can be understood by a large number
of people so the battle should be fought
in the open space of ideas
versus in
in the quiet space of journals i think
we no longer have that comfort
especially at the highest of stakes so
this kind of idea that a couple of peer
reviewers
decide the fate of billions
is
is doesn't seem to be sustainable
especially given a a very real
observation now
that um
that the reason robert malone has a
large following
is there's a deep distrust of
institutions deep distressed the
scientists of science as an institution
of power centers of companies of
of everything and perhaps rightfully so
but the way to defend against that is
not for the powerful to build a bigger
wall
it's for the powerful to be authentic
um
and maybe do a lot of them to get fired
and for new minds for new fresh
scientists
uh ones who are more authentic more real
better communicators to step up so i i
fear i fear censorship because
it feels like
censorship is a even harder job to do it
well
than
being good communicators and it seems
like it's always the c students that end
up doing the censorship
that it's like it's always the
incompetent people and not just the
incompetent
but the biggest whiners so like what
happens is
the people
that
get the most emotional and the most
outraged will drive the censorship
and it doesn't seem like reason drives
the censorship that's just objectively
observing how censorship seems to work
in this current so there's so many forms
of censorship
you know you look at the soviet union
with the propaganda or nazi germany it's
a very different level censorship people
people tend to conflate all of these
things together you know social media
trying desperately to have
trillions
or
hundreds of billions of exchanges a day
and like try to make sure that their
platform is has some
uh semblance of like
quote healthy conversations like people
just don't go insane they actually like
using the platform and they they sensor
based on that
that's a different level of censorship
but even there
you can really run a foul of the people
they get
the the the whiny c students controlling
too much of the censorship i i believe
that you should you should actually put
the responsibility
on the
self-proclaimed holders of truth aka
scientists at being better communicators
i agree with that i'm not uh advocating
for any kind of censorship but
uh marshall mcluhan was very influential
when i was in college
and his uh
that meme uh the medium is the message
it's a little bit hard to understand
when you're comparing radio to tv and
saying radio's hotter or tv's hotter or
something but we now have the medium as
the message in a way that we've never
seen we've never imagined before where
rage and anger
and polarization
are what drives the
traffic on the internet
and
we don't
it's a question of building the commons
ideally i don't know how to get there so
i'm not pretending to have a solution
but the commons of discourse
about this particular issue about
vaccines
is has been largely destroyed by the
edges by the drug companies and the
advocates on the one side and the um
people who just criticize and um think
that
even though the data are flawed that um
there's no way vaccines can be
beneficial and to have those people
screaming at each other
does nothing to improve
the health of the 95 percent of the
people in the middle who want to un
know what the rational way to go forward
is and protect their families from kovit
and
live a good life and be able to
participate in the economy and
that's the problem
i don't have a solution
you